B-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b...
I'm
currently drinking coffee.
Hopefully, it will rejuvenate me.
I actually just got back from doing many haunting errands.
So I just got back home like an hour ago.
And so...
And boy are my arms tired.
But I was seriously like...
I'm gonna sleep now.
I'm gonna eat now.
Get shorter sleeves.
No!
I like my sleeves.
They help with...
With...
Cleaning up messes.
Those sleeves do look heavy.
Ma'am, your sleeves look heavy.
Can I please help you with your...
Sleeves?
Why are her ears like that?
What do you mean?
Bet Mint wipes boogers with her sleeves.
No!
Is that why they're green?
Ew, that's gross.
Why would you say that?
That's so nasty.
God.
Why did my chat break already?
Come on, YouTube.
YouTube!
But anyway, today I was like...
Well, rather...
Tomorrow, I am...
I'm going to be going on vacation for a little bit.
And...
I was like, what's something that I can do...
That's kind of chill?
Something I haven't done in a long while.
And that's balloons!
We're returning to monkey.
My true form.
Minky.
What is this AI shit?
Oh no.
All I saw was the auto-generated...
Chat thing was that...
People are...
They said it was like...
Viewers are concerned about her...
Health habits.
I got my happy coat today.
The graphic is so sleek and shiny.
I hope you have a wonderful Christmas and have a wonderful Japan trip.
Thanks Joshua!
Oh my gosh, I'm glad you got it.
It's so soft, isn't it?
It's so nice.
I'm glad it arrived safely.
I...
I don't remember what I was going to say.
I'm so...
I'm so brain dead.
I mean, my brain is always dead.
Because I'm dead.
But you know what I mean.
I...
I can barely think.
Because I'm a monkey.
Honestly, I'm not packed at all.
I went...
And then...
My mom was just like...
Oh, by the way, we're meeting today, right?
I was like, what do you mean?
Monkey bunny!
So I was at my mom's place for a bit.
You forgot?
No, no, no.
This was the other day.
After... So basically...
I asked my mom about it today.
I was just like, hey, you said you were going to be gone for Christmas.
And so that we weren't going to have a Christmas.
And that's why we celebrated Christmas early this year.
And she's like, no.
Your sister is not going to be here for Christmas.
And I was gone last week.
So that's why we did it early.
And I was like...
Min, watch out.
There's a camel bloom behind you.
Well, good thing I have...
The camo.
I have the thermal goggles.
That's the sound of me throwing darts.
And blowing up the balloons.
Speaking of which, I went to check my YouTube today.
And one of the ideas for the inspiration section was...
Min goes on a virtual vacation with her friends.
Why would I suggest that?
Let's see what my... OK, hold on.
So if you don't know, YouTube has this new fancy feature.
Where it gives you ideas.
If you're like, I don't know what kind of...
It's called the inspiration tab.
And if you're like, I don't know what kind of video to make.
There's the inspiration tab, which is...
Which brainstorms for you.
And it's all AI.
Ideas.
Huh?
OK,
so here's my first one.
That I came up with.
Aoi-chan tries to sing high notes.
I think my channel is being taken over.
Aoi-chan's vocal range...
Why is it called Aoi-chan?
No, I'm mint, I'm not blue.
Who is Aoi-chan?
I don't know.
The next one.
The video captures Aoi-chan's reactions to the song.
Providing a humorous end.
And it cuts off there.
Mint-chan!
The next one is, VTuber sings popular songs in different genres.
Popular songs are sung by a VTuber in a variety of musical genres.
Listen as VTuber's distinct vocal style is showcased across different styles of music.
These ones are also boring today.
And then this one.
This one is so messed up.
VTuber tries a voice changing app.
I already get... I already get accused of using a voice changer all the time.
Well, maybe that's an exaggeration.
But, people are like, hi.
That's probably some guy.
It's getting Aoi-chan from your song cover 3 years ago.
I figured it was the...
Aoi-chan...
Chocomint Ice Ice Ice.
I can't remember the full title.
But you already do use one.
I do.
You guys wanna hear my real voice?
That's my real voice.
My favorite streamers in this channel, in order.
1 Lilac, 2 Aoi-chan, 3 Minto.
You forgot Mint-chan.
Voice mod stream.
A VTuber's voice is altered in unexpected ways by a voice changing app.
The results are hilarious and demonstrate the app's capabilities.
These suck.
Sometimes they're really wacky for me.
Oh yeah, the ghost that's haunting me, alright.
That's the ghost that's haunting me, alright.
It's so funny because I don't think it draws any ideas from my live streams.
It only draws ideas from my actual videos.
Which is very bizarre.
I guess YouTube doesn't consider live streams as important as normal videos.
It's strange.
Strange.
It'll always give me something about Shubidubi or like...
It'll be like, VTuber goes pop, pop, pop, pop in higher voices.
One of mine was Mint's biggest gaming fails and said this chaotic compilation will leave viewers laughing at Mint's hilarious misfortunes.
That's so mean.
Hi Minto, first time sending a superchat.
Thank you, Jacob!
Happy to be spending my birthday here watching the chill balloon stream.
You know what time it is.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Jacob.
With an R!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the first superchat.
I'm honored.
Guys, it's been a long time since I've played balloons, I'll be honest.
It's been a hot minute since I've lived the monkey life.
Mermonkey?
3 million balloons!
Get the most bottle.
I want to get the Mermonkey!
Okay guys, that's our goal today is to get the Mermonkey with 3 million balloons.
There's new ones!
This one's tricky.
Bonus reward.
Whatever this means.
Create two more maps to unlock all extra maps.
Should we try it?
The Luminous Cove?
My
coffee is strange.
It's actually my Kojima Productions coffee.
Boat time.
We need a boat in this.
I guess let's try medium.
We need to pop 3 million.
Why are there gingerbread...
This is so beautiful.
What is the path?
So they come down and then they go...
And then maybe they go...
But what about here?
Then here too?
Maybe they come down both sides?
And then they cross and sometimes they exit this way and sometimes they exit this way.
Love this game.
BTG6 was addicted...
Oh, was addicted to...
For 3 months straight.
Yeah, it sounds about me too.
Time to go bananas.
Bananas!
It looks like a uterus.
The map shape looks sus.
Stop you guys!
This map layout is sus.
Stop!
No, it's mysterious.
Look there's...
The merpeople!
The mermonkeys!
I can't unsee it now.
You guys have ruined it!
With your perverted mind!
Death penalty!
Not the balloon womb.
No!
Let's see.
Where can we even put her?
I don't know where to put her.
We're gonna do sub-optimal balloons today.
I'm so sorry everybody.
For my sub-optimal balloons positioning.
I apologize.
The bloom!
Where's Ice Monkey?
Right here!
Oh, sorry.
I'm kinda blocking, huh?
There's never a good place for me to go in the balloon streams.
Yeah, I'll just be tall.
I'll be skinny legend.
Is that okay?
Like this?
I'm like standing right next to you.
Mint, will you be going pro in balloons?
Talk to my agent, thank you.
We're going back to the bloom.
No!
Okay.
I'm gonna put Ice... No.
We're gonna start out proper with a boat.
There they go.
Here they come in.
Nice.
Chat is taller than Minto.
I could be taller.
Actually, I have a banana which makes me taller.
I got an Indiana Jones hat for Christmas because chat told me to.
I gotta say I'm 15% cooler with it on.
I wanna play Indiana Jones so bad.
Okay, now we get to see where they come... where they go.
Oh, see?
Yeah, we knew.
It's exactly what I predicted.
They'll come from the left side and then they'll come from the right side.
Okay, now we know.
Time to get another boat.
Actually, let's just line this whole area with boats.
Now we wait.
Nice.
Again.
Again!
Oh, that's a lot of blue.
That's okay.
Our boats are powerful.
Our boats are strong.
We should do... I still have yet to unlock this.
Maybe... I don't think we'll get it today, obviously, but maybe someday.
Let's do...
Honestly, I'm so slow-brained today.
I'm just like... I just wanna listen to the popping of the balloon.
The balloon popping.
Banana soupa.
Move over to center and he can be part of the cave art.
No!
You would want that, huh?
You would want me in this freakish... here, huh?
Nice.
Don't be... Actually, I was gonna say don't be freaks, but...
That's like our whole shtick.
That's like our whole thing.
You guys...
You guys, actually today...
Toho Lost Word will be doing a live stream in about like 40 minutes.
And there might be people that come here that don't know me at all and they're just like...
Oh, I'm curious about who this mint phantom fella... fella is.
I'm gonna go check her out and see what's going on.
And then they'll see us talking about the womb and that's...
That's gonna be weird!
I'm in the 23rd time sending a super chat, I think.
And one to tell you that your Santa baby cover got so many people pregnant.
No!
I'm not ready.
I'm not... I'm only... I'm only forever 19.
I'm not ready for this responsibility!
Thank you!
Of course you can!
But how I...
Do I have to say your whole legal name?
Happy... Wait.
Sorry.
I don't know if there's any...
Alright.
We're still popping?
Merry Chrysler!
My... I got a Christmas gift from my mom today.
And you know what she gifted me?
She gifted me...
No!
Not a hot dog!
That would be weird.
No, actually I got...
She gifted me, like, spatulas and stuff.
Utensils for the kitchen, but they're mint colored!
They're so cute!
Having been a Touhou fan for a very long time, I think most of us are already a little freaky.
I think actually Touhou... Becoming a Touhou fan was the start of my freakness.
And I mean that in 100% sincerity.
Touhou...
Touhou had some of the freakiest stuff going on.
I think.
I truly think it was...
It was that.
But also I consider Touhou being like...
How do I say?
Here, let's do some...
We'll do you as a carrier and you in the middle.
Or wait, let's get one more guy.
Smack dab there.
Oh, well, that's fine.
I'm a little figment of the imagination.
Weird how you should be paying as child support.
No!
Touhou is so innocent but leads to many awakenings.
Yes.
You guys, act a little bit normal.
We can scare...
We can... Well, maybe they are Touhou fans.
If they are Touhou fans, they gotta be a little freaky too.
Probably.
I think.
This guy will be...
The pirate lord.
And then this guy will be...
This one.
Alright, chat set freakers to 50%.
As if we can just turn it off.
How do you turn off the freak?
They are coming to Mint's dream.
They should know better.
No!
How would they know?
Wait, my Freak-O-Meter only goes down to 75.
I guess that's it then.
Crank up the Freak-O-Meter.
We're cranking it up.
Which one?
It's the submarine that has... We'll probably need him for the intel, right?
I imagine.
So we're gonna get this guy in here.
We're gonna have him be able to contact all other boats.
Touhou fans will see Mint and go...
Long range.
This one.
The submerge.
Yeah, we'll just go with this.
Into the middle.
We'll put him like... Wait, if I put him there, would another boat be able to fit here?
Probably not, right?
Pools on subs.
You won't... Wait, what do you mean?
Pools on subs?
Pools?
Pools.
Personally, I'm quite fond of Koishi just in case my last Super Chat was lost on it.
Thank you.
The top corners.
Top pools on subs.
So we put the subs in here.
Up here?
The ovary pools.
If these are the ovaries, then what are these?
Like an ovarian cyst?
The ovaries too?
The backups?
The balls.
The sequel.
Fertilized eggs.
That's not where they go.
Open the skulls!
Are you a big hat or a big bow kind of person?
I love both, but personally I'm a big hat believer, baby.
BabyCorn, thanks for the gifted.
I meant that my birthday is on the 30th.
As you are to leave, could I please have a personalized happy birthday?
I know I already thanked you for the generalize one yesterday, but I'm greedy.
Yeah!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Viridian Delta!
Happy birthday!
My first exposure to Touhou was the Ronald McDonald mashup.
This is it!
I just woke up and I see Minto legs.
Am I still dreaming?
Get out of here.
Go back to sleep.
Also, I'm sorry your mom didn't get you a hotdog.
Here's one on me.
I don't want a hotdog.
Wouldn't the bloons be eggs in the bloom?
Or is it something else?
I really don't like this level anymore.
I don't think I like this level anymore.
Okay, we're saving up.
Cannon.
Saving up.
What's this?
Nice.
I think you need more monkey.
No, not yet.
Not yet.
Look at our guys.
They're so powerful.
I'm Minto.
I'm also on December 30th birthday ever.
How do you guys feel about having a birthday that is...
That is so close to... How is it that...
If you were born...
Wait, that's the 30th, not the 31st.
Just B-E-C-I.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday just B-C-E-R.
Wait, B-E-C-R.
Happy birthday to you.
Spooky echo.
Spooky.
Wait.
He can shoot them!
Oh my god!
He can hit the camos!
We have... We have a guy.
Let's get this guy in.
I'm going to sandwich him right here.
We can put guys on either side of him.
There we go.
Okay.
As a 23rd of December birthday haver, it might as well be the same day.
Wait, same day as what?
I love how everybody is coming out being like, oh by the way, my birthday too!
I can't sing happy birthday for everybody, but...
Beep-beep, happy birthday!
I did do the generalized birthday you guys, so that you know if I miss any birthdays while I'm gone.
Camo.
What do you mean camo?
Oh my gosh, Kudo is so cute.
I love... She's so cute.
Chat is greedy.
What did you expect?
You know what?
I am too, so...
Maybe chat really does reflect the streamer, huh?
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Beep-Beeps!
Are all the maps designed to look like organs?
Possibly.
I want to get this destroyer.
Submerge.
Actually, sorry, I spent all my money.
This year was a mixed bag, but deciding to watch Mervinto was a silver lining.
Thanks Jordan!
Safe travels, I appreciate it.
So much, thank you.
How many balloons have we popped so far, I wonder?
My birthday is on the 31st too.
What do you mean two?
Everybody else said the 30th.
Though the calendar does not mark this day as the anniversary of my birth, may I with deepest humility and utmost reverence and...
What are you talking about?
It is not your birthday.
Then why am I singing a birthday song?
Get in line.
You need like 150 plus run to get to 3 mil.
Dang!
Okay, we can get there though today, I think.
Maybe.
Okay, maybe it's time to start also investing in money.
There's so many things to worry about, I'm just a monkey.
I'm just a monkey, there's too many things to worry about in this monkey world.
There's too many things to be on my little monkey mind.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Samoponume.
Look, you guys, the mermaid monkey is right here.
We have to unlock him.
We have to get there.
Nice.
Mermaid monkey.
Where can I even put...
Where can I even put... I guess like...
Down here.
I can fit maybe...
One?
I think I can only fit one.
Bottom path.
Yeah, I'm working on it with this guy.
Actually, you know what, let's just upgrade him.
Right now.
This map feels bad.
It's called a challenge.
The maps get pretty tricky though, right?
Just more merchant boats.
I think we'll do that, probably.
More merchants.
But for now, I think it's good to also upgrade so that we can...
So that we can...
This guy shows the camels, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So maybe we'll do this.
Hot shot.
It's not my birthday, but I'm leaving for a vacation to Sweden on Sunday.
Ice skating on the Baltic Sea.
Wow!
Have fun, Senshi.
Oh my god.
That sounds amazing.
Plus 200!
Oh my gosh!
It's a MOAB!
Easy.
We're so good at this game.
Handle it.
MOAB.
I wanna put her in somewhere.
Put her in coach.
Maybe she can just like chill at the end.
Actually, isn't she really great at the beginning?
But we can't put her in the beginning.
We can put her in the middle.
Monkey in the middle.
Feels weird not having someone... She wouldn't even say handle it.
Let's make another boat.
This one will also be...
So this side...
I don't know.
Never mind.
I lied.
I don't know anymore.
I know.
This is my favorite Saada skin.
Actually, it's like my favorite... It's like my favorite Minky... Monkey skin.
My favorite monkey skin.
I love to skin the monkeys.
I'm skinning the monkeys.
I'm skinning them.
Minky!
So far, so good though.
So far, this could be way worse.
31,000.
Craziness.
We wanna make more money.
I personally like Sushi Ben more, but Saada skin is really good.
I think it's because, you know, it's a spooky ghost.
I'm biased, obviously.
I'm biased, I'm biased, I'm biased.
Like, I admit it.
I admit my, you know, my biases.
It was my birthday earlier this week.
Did I not sing for you?
Why did you tell me?
I was shy.
Shut up!
No!
Why were you... What?
I was shy.
I can't believe this.
Let's do...
Another round.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Orbital Vagabond!
I'm just... Here I am.
You guys are just like, sing for me!
Sing for me, Minky!
Sing me happy birthday!
It's my birthday in September.
Do you remember?
Danibus' birthday in September.
Sing it for the next year.
My birthday is in 10 months from now.
Why does this always happen when I go away?
Now... Wait.
No, the carrier flagship, we can put stuff on top, right?
Maybe we can put her on top of the ship.
Maybe.
Yeah!
Little planes!
Look at them go!
Backlogged birthdays.
Crazy, I was crazy once.
Someone said that there was a December version of it.
My birthday is next month.
Will you be there, please?
I should!
You mean next year.
I know that it's like...
Your birthday is once a year, but it feels different for January.
You have to wait a whole year.
Until your birthday.
I mean, I know everybody has to do that, but I feel like it's...
If my birthday was in January, I feel like I would be like, wow, I have to wait a whole year.
You know?
Like, it has a different feeling than if it's smack in the middle of the year.
Mine's in January?
Brucey, do you feel that way?
Do you feel like, oh my gosh, I have to wait until the new year.
I have no birthday.
That's a lie.
My birthday is the same as the release of the...
Minecraft movie!
I think discovering this cute ghost man was probably one of my highlights of 2034.
Have a good Japan trip and happy new year!
Thank you!
I know everybody has to wait a whole year for their birthday, but it just feels different.
You guys don't understand.
You guys don't... You guys...
Come on!
It's different because it's the start of the new year, so you're like, oh my gosh, it must feel different.
I feel.
Wait, what did I just do?
Oh, attacks faster and generates more money.
More money.
I have a birthday in January and I don't understand what the hell you mean.
Nobody understands my genius.
It's so hard being me.
God!
You say this like you have a January.
No, I'm just saying if I had one, I would probably feel this way.
But maybe people who have January birthdays are just like, girl, I don't know what you're talking about.
Maybe it's different.
I have no idea.
Wait, what did I...
Monkeys in radius have increased cell value.
Oh my gosh, we're selling off our monkeys.
You also act like I have a birthday.
I have a death day, which I use as a birthday.
I understand you.
You are correct.
Thank you.
I think having a birthday on February 29th...
Wait, think of having a birthday...
February 29th, because then you have to wait 4 years for your birthday.
And you just don't age.
It's the best thing.
How much money do we make?
Oh, we make an extra thousand.
Let's go.
Wait, this guy...
Okay.
What do we want to go for?
For the big upgrade.
More money.
Let's make more minky money guys here.
Merchant man.
More money!
I just wanted to mention it before New Year's.
No worries, since you'll be gone next year busy probably even after.
We're not interested.
What do you mean?
I wanted to mention Year Walk.
A spooky puzzle game about New Year's.
Wait!
I mean I'll be back a little bit after New Year's.
It'll still feel like New Year's maybe.
That's my birthday tomorrow!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Brian!
With an L.
Happy birthday to you!
Not my birthday.
Luna, thank you so much for the paint!
After watching Vtubers for years, you finally convinced me to start hobby streaming.
Thanks for being you, inspiring everyone to do their best.
Good luck!
Down payment for my...
30th birthday next year.
If I don't get a girlfriend by then, could you please summon Lilac to wish me a happy 30th birthday?
With her sexy Onee-san voice.
Okay.
Sure.
The fanartist just needed a reference for Minky's.
Just have to put the monkeys and bloons.
But you have to actually try to get a girlfriend, you know?
You can't just half-ass it, I'm telling you.
I'm gonna put this guy in the middle.
Wait, no.
Why would I put him in the middle?
Because no bloons come around here.
Okay, hold on.
Wait.
Here.
And this guy is going to become...
A ballistic missile.
Nice.
Wait, what's this one?
Longer range.
Nice.
We gonna sabotage you.
Don't say that!
Why would you say that?
Guys is trying to be happy.
We did it!
Free play.
Alright, nice.
How much?
Let's see what our...
Wow, we actually got so far.
We are almost to this one.
For real.
Let's go.
I'm just gonna send him on and maybe...
My birthday was a week ago.
So instead of happy birthday, can I get your best...
Like.
Happy birthday.
CC MC Shaggy.
Can I get an...
No!
Actually so good.
Last time I did a Shaggy impression, people were like...
Wow, man.
That really sucks.
Wow, that was terrible.
I'll also try and get a girlfriend.
Stop!
I'm standing right here.
You guys are deranged today.
What's going on?
Is it because you are in like a monkey mood?
You are just like...
The monkeys make me silly.
Can I get an...
Too much eggnog.
You guys...
I hope Santa is looking at all this, you know?
I hope Santa is viewing all of this and is just like...
Oh, gosh.
More money, please.
Monkey make us extra freaky.
What's that?
You and me, baby.
Ain't nothing but monkey.
Guys, we are so strong.
Let's do this and then we'll...
This, this.
There we go.
And...
Generates more cash per round.
Increase cash earned up to 20 other merchantmen.
More money!
Everyone knows Santa doesn't count between December 25th and January 1st for his list.
That's not true!
I know he's taking time off, but he has elves probably that are still on the hunt.
There has to be.
So I need to make more merchantmen, right?
How much did we make?
I don't know.
Elves like you.
I'm not an elf.
Where would you get this idea from?
This is like the purge time for Santa's list.
That's so bad.
If you consider this to be the purge time for Santa's list, you truly deserve to be on the naughty list.
Permanently.
Only coal, only coal, only coal for you.
Their hormones are all over the place.
Why did this happen?
I'm not encouraging this at all, you guys.
Me!
You're freaking me out!
And I'm... I'm always freaked.
It's the map choice.
I didn't think about...
Let's see, what else should we make?
Actually, let's save up for...
Something.
What does this one do?
Adds extra pierce and damage to commander and all subs in its radius.
If this is the bloom, then whose bloom is it?
Bloonarius.
Who is that?
Guys, we're killing it!
What was the bad... Wait, what was the round that gets super difficult?
Which round is that?
Wait.
80?
76 has the dense ceramic round.
80.
You've heard of Elf on the Shelf, now get ready for Ghost on the Toast.
Oh my gosh, a mint toaster?
Can you imagine?
And if you use the toaster, it...
It prints my face on it.
Kind of like when people see those Jesus toasts.
They're just like, wow!
Oh my god, he's here in my toast!
You could say that, but I'm like, haunting your toast.
Wait, no, I want that.
And then...
And then you would get like a jam.
But, what kind of jam would be mint colored?
I wonder.
What jam would be mint colored?
Mint jam.
I don't think that would taste good though.
I don't know if that would taste good.
And then...
I like this boat.
It doesn't look like it's doing anything.
It's just carrying cargo and it's like, I'm also helping.
Let's see.
Let's do faster shots.
Elf honey.
What?
Is this game any good?
Oh, if you like tower defense, yeah, it's a lot of fun.
I recommend.
And it goes on sale a lot too.
So you can usually get it for a decent price.
What should we put on here, you guys?
Maybe sniper monkey?
We could put soda monkey.
She's not gonna reach anything though.
Ice monkey.
I usually stack two snipers.
I'm thinking that too.
Can it fit two up here?
Or is it one, one?
Ice monkey.
You guys, if I put ice monkey here, he won't reach.
Actually, he does kind of reach.
Tiny, tiny bit.
Just plain ice monkey.
I don't know which upgrade should we go with.
Elite defender or the cripple MOAB?
Cripple is good.
I vote MOAB.
Okay.
You should also be able to see... the what's it called, right?
You should be able to see camo.
So we don't need the night... Wait, what's this one though?
Oh, the shrapnel.
But he's in the range of this, so he should be able to see night vision, right?
Or the camo ones, right?
Mint jelly is an actual real thing.
Smuckers makes it?
What?
Is it any good?
The sub doesn't give camo vision.
Submerge to detect camo.
He can't see the camo when it goes by.
Okay then.
Oh, that was so fast.
MOAB.
Handle it.
Do you think he'll kill anyone?
Do you think he'll pop any bloons?
Ice monkey's got an easy life.
Ice monkey really doesn't have to do anything.
Oh yeah, let's set him to strong.
Good idea.
He's chilling.
He's just our... He's like our mascot, little ice monkey.
Juggle for me, monkey.
Juggle!
Entertain me!
Juggle, monkey, juggle!
Oh my god, so sorry.
Oh my god.
I had the Touhou last word...
I had the Touhou last word stream up.
It scared the heck out of me.
I kinda wanna watch.
You guys are gonna be talking about me.
It's craziness.
I don't wanna watch.
We'll watch along.
Should we?
I don't think I would be able to play it though.
I might be able to show it.
I don't want them to get mad at me though.
Hold on, let me...
I'm gonna put it...
Here, down here.
On my monitor.
There we go.
So I can see it.
I'm gonna keep playing Bloons for now.
It's just like a loading screen.
Woman.
You!
You're the woman.
Where are you going for vacation?
Japan?
Why?
How long...
Wait!
I'm gonna message you right now.
Woman.
I love the way she talks to me.
God!
Yay!
Oh, wait.
OK.
Sorry, I'm typing my love to her.
Yay!
Brian, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
It's the big guy.
I think we got this.
I'm gonna eat it.
Nice.
Wow, we got lots of money too.
Let's upgrade...
This?
I thought I had that already.
I did not.
Kiara, if you're still here, have you ever played Bloons?
It's so addicting.
Actually, it's so addicting.
Just watching all the Bloons, watching them all pop and everything.
Mintori Teitei.
Bring back the Teitei!
I have no idea what this is.
It's just a tower defense thing.
You set up little monkeys and then you pop the Bloons.
It's really satisfying to watch them all go...
Arcanize with monkeys.
Yeah, pretty much.
Show her the hot monkey.
Which...
Which one?
I'm trying to get Murmonkey right now.
But I like this.
This is my main monkey.
She's really cute.
Her name is Sada.
I'm not using her right now though because this is a boats...
Only boats level.
Look at this guy.
The Pirate Lord!
Oh my gosh, if we just had enough...
We would be able to get the three.
Oh, I'm looking at the Touhou last word thing.
They say today's announcement.
But the last one is about me.
So we'll wait until the last announcement.
Guys, do you think we're good for the round 92 or whatever one was the spooky one?
Do you think we'll be okay?
I'm scared.
Eat this!
Sorry, I'm like half watching the stream.
I'm so sorry.
Upgrade sniper.
Oh yeah!
Thank you.
Yeah, we'll get him.
Well, once I have the money.
I gotta have the monkey money, you know.
He gets eaten.
Get eaten, get eaten.
Literally just yoinked him out of existence.
I'm gonna maybe do another merchant boat.
We're gonna make so much money.
Merchant boat.
I can't squeeze him in.
No!
You know who would be able to fit there?
Mermonkey.
Mermonkey would be able to fit there.
Ice monkey.
Ice monkey doesn't know how to swim.
Don't give him that kind of responsibility.
Look at this though.
We're killing it.
Get eaten.
Alright, we're close to be able to... Maybe probably next round we'll be able to upgrade...
You!
Come on!
Just a little bit more money!
And...
Upgrade.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
So now we have you, you...
This guy, let's do...
What's this one?
This one?
We'll do this one.
We'll do the grape shots.
And this one...
Adds extra pierce and damage to commander and all subs.
We should add more subs up here.
We'll fill this area with submarines.
We lived!
Oh my god.
Sniper monkey.
Sniper monkey killed it.
Oh my god.
Keep going.
Blow
him up!
Blow him up!
Nice.
Put him in a headlock.
They never saw it coming.
What one should this guy be?
What one should this little friend be?
Monkey sub.
What should he be?
Bottom.
With a sub commander.
Middle, bottom.
More missiles is good.
Which one is that?
Oh yeah, the ballistic missiles.
I like these ones a lot.
That is true.
We'll go for middle.
Nice.
Now we save up to upgrade.
Well, we also need to upgrade this guy.
Now that Kiwawa has asked you on a date, I'm asking for your blessing to ask a fellow wisp out?
A fellow wisp?
Who?
Ice Monkey, will you marry me?
I meant it was my birthday tomorrow.
I wanted to say thank you for a wonderful year.
As a new wisp, I have enjoyed your content and brain rot.
I do have those.
Your freaky personality has made me so happy with laughter.
I look forward to 2035.
Saikou, thank you!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Saikou.
Happy birthday!
Look, if you guys want to start dating and whatever, that's fine, but like...
Don't forget about me though.
OK?
I don't know.
I'm needy a little bit sometimes.
I'm whatever.
I don't know.
Who is mint?
I'm gonna lose it.
I'm gonna lose it for real.
Gonna lose it for real.
Can I have your blessing to date Ayami Mama?
Hey, if you join membership, you become boyfriend with Ayami.
So honestly...
I mean, you're kind of competing with like...
We didn't even lose a life though.
I wonder if I should get this guy.
If we should get this guy, because he'll generate lives for us.
Which one is it?
This one.
Jungle bounty.
My freaky Yoshi is parasocial?
No?
Look,
he's right next to Mermonkey.
They're probably besties.
I'm gonna put him right here.
Wait, this is the middle path, right?
Yeah, middle path.
Can I have your blessing to marry a Wisp?
It's pretty easy to become a marriage officiant online.
If you do that, you can attend every Wisp wedding and marry all of us.
Why is this turning into like Hinge?
What is this?
37 million... Stop!
It's such a female who's freaky.
It's a freaky ghost.
What is this?
This is not like an online chat room.
It's coughing season.
Is that... What is that?
Are you going to jail?
What is a coughing season?
Coughing season?
Because you get sick?
Is it like a...
Hydrogen bomb versus coughing baby.
Hydrogen bomb versus coughing season.
Permission to get another Wisp pregnant.
Denied!
Stop getting pregnant!
Stop!
Stop pregnancy!
Stop getting pregnant!
Stop getting pregnant right now!
Question for my fellow Wisp ASL...
I can't win.
I returned to what happened.
Don't worry about it.
If you don't know that's fine.
I feel like I missed some important context here.
No, no, there is no context.
I don't think.
It's just that everybody is...
Everybody...
Everybody is...
I'm going to put this guy here.
He also makes money.
We gotta upgrade our guys.
Oh boy, 2 AM.
No!
Hi Pinto, it's also my birthday tomorrow.
Can I get a song?
So have fun on your trip.
Thank you Xiaorulu!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Xiaorulu.
Happy birthday!
I don't know what is happening in this stream, but I'm highly infused.
Is my pain enjoyment for you?
Not gonna lie, I probably have a better chance of finding someone special here on your channel compared to the real Jews on Tinder, Hinge and Bumble combined.
You know, that's so fair.
Hot single wisps in your area looking to get freaky.
I guess that's kind of true.
Probably would have a better chance, right?
Do people still use Tinder anymore?
I only mentioned Hinge because I keep getting ads for them.
Like what are you trying to say, huh?
I keep getting ads for Hinge.
They are going hard on the advertising.
It's hell out there.
I heard Tinder is almost only hookups now.
Tinder is still the most popular.
Looking for femboy wisps.
Should we just have like a blind date stream or something?
I'll just sit here and you guys all figure it out in chat.
I'll sit here and you guys all be like...
Okay, you guys go...
Speed dating.
Hashtag wisp bingle.
Okay, I'm just gonna play Bloons now then and you guys can figure it out.
My ears!
It was getting so rumbly.
Would any wisp in chat like to accompany me to a black tie formal event in San Jose, California next June?
What is going on in June?
I can afford it.
Let's go!
Anybody here like redubers?
Look!
It's expanding!
I can't... I can't... I can't grab it.
Okay, round 100!
Yeah baby!
I'm gonna add another... Wait.
Oh this guy is close to upgrading.
We'll just do the next one and then we'll upgrade him.
Oh wait.
No, we want to upgrade this guy instead.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
There we go.
Wait, I died?
Our monkey star with the one million pops.
Let's go!
Oh, it was a bunch of DDTs.
I didn't even see it happen.
Me neither!
I lost it all.
Wait, hold on.
By the power of Battle Cat... Hold on.
I have two million more pops.
Two!
Two and a half!
Over two and a half million more to pop.
Nice black lady.
That's cute.
I'm still watching too.
Battle Cat.
That's another fun game, Battle Cat.
Wait.
We only got...
We only got 300,000?
How is that possible when our one guy got one million?
Why didn't it do all of the balloons?
I'm so confused.
My happy catman.
Yeah!
Goat.
Goat-men-nashai.
Thank you so much for ordering it.
Came by to say I completed Jingle Freaks and enjoyed which everyone should complete.
Thank you!
The game can't math.
No!
Are we getting scammed?
You guys are getting scammed for real.
It's pops, not damage.
Layers don't count, only individual balloons.
No!
You got the monkey money, so losing at round 102 is basically min-maxing.
You know it's so true.
So true.
Oh wait.
The who is a secret because they're watching, but you can find out if I'm successful.
I do not think I will.
No!
Wait, why don't you think you'll be successful with the day?
Wait, they're watching?
Who is it?
Is it Neon?
Is it Justifan?
Is it Gabriel?
Who is it?
Is it Garlamon?
I can't remember which all of you actually are married and stuff.
I can't remember.
Is it Co-op?
Who is it?
Is it Yuki?
Is it Verilin?
Who is it?
Is it Enchel?
It's a thousand percent me.
It's Shaggy.
IrishJive, welcome to the FanFu Show.
Thank you.
You're just gonna list everyone?
Yeah, is it Fae?
Is it Fae?
Is it Invader?
Is it Nashi?
Is it Jovec?
Haha, couldn't be me.
Jovec, aren't you also in a relationship?
I can't remember.
Is it Delaran?
If only it was me.
It could be you, Derpyus.
Yeah, he has a man already.
Yeah, yeah, I remember.
I remember.
I am, but my boyfriend has a normal sleep schedule and is always sleeping during your streams.
Stop!
I'm not part of this drama.
But I'm the cause of the drama.
I'm not part of it, but I'm the cause.
She's such a freak.
She's a super freak.
Super freak.
She's super freaky.
Why have I never sung that song?
Why has nobody ever asked me to sing that song in karaoke?
It's literally our song.
Nobody has ever asked us.
I have requested it.
No, you're just saying that.
We have?
Wait, no you haven't.
Wait, you have?
What is it called?
No.
We have?
No, it's called Super Freak.
Maybe I thought you guys were kidding.
Maybe I thought you guys were like...
We're like gaslighting.
I don't know.
Not gaslighting, but you know...
You know what I mean.
Maybe I thought you guys were just calling me a freak.
I don't know.
That's so silly.
I'm gaslighting you right now.
Hi Minky.
Hi!
I did!
Thank you!
Lucia, thank you!
Minky, thank you.
Still waiting on Invisible 2.
I know!
I'm gonna get to it.
I wanna do like a fuller Metal Gear themed karaoke.
While waiting in line for the concert, one of the horse carriages across the street started blaring Super Freak.
It was quite appropriate.
Horse carriages?
The old Atlanta had horse carriages.
Mint will learn the best is yet to come.
I've actually been trying, but not in the Gaelic, you know, because it's kind of hard.
But, you know...
Love Steam though?
Horse carriage did pass by the line.
Really?
That's so awesome.
Wait, do not Midwest cities have horse carriages?
Do all cities have a horse carriage?
I feel like I've seen horse carriages, but I've only seen them in movies.
So, like, I always thought that they were just like a...
I'm in New York and I'm on a horse carriage.
What's up, cities?
There's a novel to you.
Requesting telephone number by Junko Ohashi.
This isn't karaoke!
Let me write that down.
Where's mine?
There it is.
NYC definitely has a ton of horse carriages, right?
I feel like I've seen them in movies.
Wow!
Oh, that's an elf.
That's an elf.
Oh, nope, that's a ninja monkey.
Why is this guy looking at me funny?
I don't like it.
Events.
Contested territory, odyssey.
There's so much going on in Bloons.
I just like to play vanilla Bloons, you know.
Multiple elves on screen.
There's this guy.
Him.
Next time you go to Otakutani, I should try it in the old port.
If anything, I'm surprised Mata didn't drag you to a ride.
I went to the old port.
I went to the old port, but I think it was because it was late at night.
Maybe there were no horses around.
Elf on the shelf.
I modded you into this game once.
Wait, was that you?
I saw one time, it was like this guy who plays a bunch of Bloons.
And he was like, I'm trying out this spooky ghost mod.
And it was just me.
How do I... Wait, oh, what we're... Hold on, play...
Oh, we unlocked some.
Wow.
We unlocked a ton.
Midnight Mansion looks fun.
Is it community?
Oh, here we go.
We can go to the Walmart.
Bloons shoplift from Walmart map, that's really good.
POV around the naughty list map.
What is this?
Standard longest map half speed.
Arctic night kind of goes really hard.
Into the storm.
Unknown ruins.
It's a... What's it called?
It's a Pokemon.
Oh, these are featured.
Let's see, most liked.
Oh, see, I've liked this one.
Interstellar is so cool, I like this one.
Oh my god.
Bore.
Guess we do in Bloons.
These are so good.
I made a mistake with my Christmas turkey and now my house is being haunted by a poultrygeist.
Any idea how to deal with this foul spirit?
No, you're so screwed, man.
Sorry.
Maxwell.
How do people do the...
How do they go so fast?
I know that's not Maxwell, but I'm just curious.
Practice.
What is that?
That's insane.
Space is water.
These are so crazy looking.
Guys, let's search for a map.
What should I look up?
Search mint.
Arctic mint.
Bombard.
Mint.
Mint monkey.
That's just a random polar bear.
Mint fuzzball.
Mint toe.
These are the same ones as before though.
Yeah.
I think I played both of these.
Mint toe.
Made of mint toe.
Right there.
In your Bloons.
More likely than you think.
Way more likely than you think.
Search brain rot.
I'm scared.
None of these make sense.
Wait, I want to look up FNAF.
What?
See, this one is good.
That one is pretty good.
Search Freddy.
Yeah, Freddy.
It's the...
It's the artistic...
Like...
Disparity.
I don't think... Oh my god.
I don't think that there will be any Metal Gear ones because...
You guys, Bloons is for children.
But I'll search.
Metal.
It's looking pretty grim.
Nothing.
You take that back.
Try MGS.
It's the Psycho Mantis room.
It's the same guy who did both of them.
You guys, this deserves more likes.
And Vulcan Raven's Canyon.
No way!
Which one should we do?
This one we are going to do with only Ice Monkey.
Oh my god, are these supposed to... Wait, no.
These are the cameras.
That's so cool.
Ice Monkey.
We can't afford him.
Will this count towards the Mermonkey?
I wonder.
Oh, there's Ice Monkey.
What was the last problem?
The last time I tried using only Ice Monkey and...
Uh-oh.
Ice Monkey, stop being so slow.
Ice Monkey.
Yikes.
The ice in me and Bloons.
I don't think so because it's custom.
Oh no.
Let's go for... I guess we'll go for this one.
Since it's the one that I have most unlocked.
Uh-oh.
Oh no.
Oh god.
We're so dead.
Permafrost strong?
OK.
Oh god.
Guys!
The way they slow... What?
There's no time for juggling right now, Ice Monkey.
Guys, this is a real battle.
This is so bad.
Wait, if your hands are like this, what's clapping?
You don't see my thighs?
It's my thighs clapping.
Duh.
Nice.
Oh my gosh, we can't afford another guy yet.
We're at 50 health.
Guys, we're in so much trouble.
We're in so much trouble.
Guys, I'm watching.
This is it.
This is the end of us.
Nice.
We can afford a second Ice Monkey!
OK, nice.
Monkeys don't belong in Alaska.
It sounds like something else.
I'm not going to lie.
What do you mean by that?
Did we lose any lives?
I wasn't looking.
Sorry.
I'm gonna turn down the volume and get your... I'm literally clapping.
What's wrong?
I'm just clapping along with the Ice Monkey.
Oh my god.
Fast.
Nice.
We got that permafrost.
They're still slow.
Nice.
Guys, I think maybe on the last word...
I might be coming up.
Here we go.
Oh no.
We lost lives.
Oh gosh.
Just keep going until I die.
Hold on.
Wait.
What's this?
Deep freeze.
Attack faster.
We need to faster.
Stay freaky, Minto.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
We're not gonna make it.
We're still not gonna make it.
Santiago, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Minto, banana monkey.
I didn't throw.
It's just... It's just... It ain't easy.
Being...
A monkey.
Defeat on Vulcan Raven.
Nicholas, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Do you plan on playing Stellar Blade?
I have an extra DLC code for the game if you'd like it.
Not offered to someone else.
I currently don't have any plans to play it, but thank you Brandon.
Yeah, please give it to someone else.
Monkey, monkey, monkey, monkey, monkey, monkey.
We died!
Thank you for the gifted.
Juggalug, thanks for the 8 months.
Spicy Cheese, thanks for the 3 months.
Being cheesy.
Search for a Touhou map.
True!
I'll just search... Touhou.
Oh my god!
Touhou Reimu.
Wait, there's actually...
There's actually so much.
Mistia Izakaya.
Wait, someone asked me about that earlier.
I saw your super chat.
I do have... I have... I have it...
I have Mistia's Izakaya.
I own it.
So, I could play it whenever.
KC Roger, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
These are so cute.
This Reimu is so cute.
Marisa Hakurei.
Marisa Hakurei is kind of cracked.
That's so cute.
Marisa, a sad Touhou project.
Fuumon.
I thought I was gonna have to put in Reimu or something, you know?
Where's Bad Apple?
They couldn't even put Bad Apple in Bloons.
SMH.
Thank you, it's the best thing to come in 2024.
Thank you, Mr. Phantom.
Why do you have my name?
The Touhou maps are good on here.
I like this just... Just Marisa.
This one's so cool, how they made Yomu's hair like the rocks.
I wonder if, like, with this one, if the Bloons look like the Danmaku coming all over, you know?
I made a map for you a while back.
The code is...
Do I put it in here?
Where do I put it?
You wanna read it and let a chat member get it?
Sure!
They can just put it in the chat.
Caps?
No...
Where do I put in a...
Where would I put in a code?
It says code here, hold on.
Z...
F-M-E-M-Y-D.
It doesn't find it.
Turn off filters.
I don't have any... Wait, what filters?
I don't have any filters on.
I'm not sure.
Sorry.
I wanna try it though.
Map gone.
Sad, sad, sad.
Maybe I got purged?
Can that happen?
Here is a DLC for Stellar Blade if anybody wants it.
2DP3JFJ8FDB.
Claim.
Somebody claim.
Sleeper cell wisp just got activated.
You might be able to search Mint or Matara.
I tried Mint earlier.
Let's try searching Matara.
Nope.
Good.
Mintara.
Nothing.
Good.
Doki burn.
Doki.
What is this?
Hmm.
Ghost?
Why are these so cursed?
Why are these all so cursed?
Ghost beach.
Ghost leg?
Ghost hunters.
Ghost trail.
Thank you Minto.
Thank you!
What are you talking about?
Why are you thanking me?
Let's see Kiara.
Let's try Hololive.
No.
Kiwawa.
None.
Sad.
Where is the people making the maps?
Vtuber.
Yeah, try Vtuber.
I remade my Vtuber model into a map.
Cute!
The single Vtuber on here.
Henya.
None.
One for Henya.
Fauna.
Look how cute the sapling!
Cute.
Very sad I think it got purged.
I can view it.
It doesn't show on the search even with the code.
I'm so sorry.
That's so messed up.
Why would it get purged?
Try Dokia.
I already tried Dokia earlier.
Try Wisp.
Wisp.
This is something very different.
Wisp forest.
Oh, this one looks cool.
Actually, it looks like little wisps.
But wisp is just like also like a word, you know.
Might not be published yet.
Oh yeah, could you republish it maybe?
Try Maid.
It's me!
Gura.
That's definitely...
She turned herself into a bush Morty.
Nice.
Takodachi garden.
Cute.
What else?
Maybe like Iron Mouse.
No.
Mousey.
Who else?
Amelia.
That sure is Sonic the Hedgehog.
I don't...
I don't
know how I'm logging it.
Oh gosh.
Why is there only one page?
This one's great though.
This one's so good.
None for Sonic.
Pecora.
None.
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
Wait, maybe not nice.
I have to ask.
Sorry, I just was watching the Lost Word thing and they announced...
The concert that they're doing.
June 28th.
And I wanted to go.
But I didn't know when the date was going to be.
And I was like, oh my gosh, what if it interferes with Ofukai?
I was like, what if it interferes with Ofukai?
But it doesn't.
It doesn't.
But there was also something else that I need to do in June, so...
Hmm...
I will have to see.
Rip Ofukai I guess.
What are you talking about?
I just said it works.
No, it's all good.
It's the week after.
Yeah, I'm busy busy.
Busy busy.
If you skip Ofukai I will die.
What are you talking about?
Hi Ice Minky.
Hi!
I haven't been able to watch much over the holidays, but I just want to thank you for being silly and hope you have fun in Japan.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, I'm gonna watch...
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna watch...
I'm gonna, I'm gonna un-Minky.
Goodbye.
And I'm going to...
Put on...
Or I'm going to have a Touhou Lost Word.
But I'm not gonna have, sorry, I'm not gonna have like the audio, cause I...
I...
I'm not...
Think I can do that.
It's excellent.
Thank you!
Thanks for ordering it!
Today is a bit of a shorter stream, so I really wanted to watch the Lost Word thing.
And play just a little bit of Bloons.
Right before I leave, you know.
You should link it here.
I will.
I'm just writing something.
I'm writing something up first.
Text.
Wait, hold on.
But then I'm gonna copy and duplicate it.
Duplicate, there we go.
Okay.
And then, watching...
Watching...
Touhou Lost Word...
Dev...
Stream.
And...
To think this is our last stream of the year.
I know, right?
That's so silly.
And then you can watch it here.
Touhou...
Lost Word...
Dev...
Stream.
And you're probably just like, why are we watching this, Minkyu?
It's because...
They're gonna be talking about me!
And I want you guys...
Um...
To see!
And I also wanna see what they're saying.
I imagine...
How long are their dev streams usually?
Like an hour?
Probably?
So I imagine...
Probably...
Oh, that one's an hour and a half.
That one's an hour.
We'll see.
But also, I'm starting to get so sleepy, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
I'm getting so sleepy.
I'm starting to get like...
So I'm just kind of like...
I just have more to do before I leave.
I didn't sleep much last night.
I fell asleep at like 5 AM.
And then I had to wake up early for an appointment I had.
And the appointment was at...
9.
So I was like...
They said...
Oh, they just said that's it.
So maybe...
Go sleep.
I gotta sleep!
Oh, sorry.
If you heard that, I just kicked my mic.
Oh.
Special announcement.
Wait, I'm gonna type too.
Who is that?
Oh
my god, that's me!
I'm embarrassed right now.
Wait.
I'm embarrassed.
Yeah, I'm gonna get rid of monkey.
Goodbye monkey.
That's true.
It took me a really long time to record this song.
I'm in the chat.
I'm so embarrassed.
I heard it literally yesterday.
Like last night I heard it.
The cover.
A few
things.
Presents.
Did you like it?
It's hard to say because I love the Kotoko version so much.
I hope everybody else likes it though.
What?
We're in a preview?
No!
Here, I'm gonna move this up here.
I'm sorry.
It's funny because I really don't know Kassen's theme very much at all.
But I love this song so much.
They stopped it right before the chorus.
The tease.
I was ready to jam out.
The chorus is so hard.
Thank you.
BGM present.
On the 8th.
As soon as I get back from Japan.
I'm gonna be so jet lagged.
I'm trying to listen to the Touhou stream.
Can you please keep it down?
Oh sorry.
That's me.
I'm a ghost maid.
Virtual YouTuber.
I play through a variety of games.
It's true.
And my favorite Touhou characters.
I stream on YouTube.
I'm streaming right now.
Yeah, that's me.
Maid Mint CH.
Someone said you look punchable.
I'll punch them.
Special live stream.
On the 8th.
I'm gonna be so jet lagged.
Yeah, I'm streaming right now.
I'm streaming right now.
Do they know?
I don't think so.
I don't think they know.
Do they know?
Wait, is this true?
You're streaming right now?
Jet stream.
More stuff!
You can get the Mint Phantom signature.
Actually, I'll be going to their offices and signing them when I'm over there.
Log in 14 days and reply to the campaign post with the screenshot hashtag LWMint.
For a chance to win a signature.
Or Fumo?
Hashtag.
LW risk.
There you go.
You can take it anytime.
Oh, Blue Sky.
They don't have a Blue Sky account yet.
What?
I think a lot of Touhou fans went to Blue Sky though because apparently ZUN got banned off of Twitter or something.
So a lot of Touhou fans went to...
Went to Blue Sky because of it.
What?
Why?
I don't know.
It's just random.
It's funny because my friend, she also got banned off of Twitter.
She's like, I never know what you're doing anymore.
I don't have Twitter.
Someone said hacked.
New Year's giveaway login bonus.
What is this?
Cute.
Yeah, I got a custom URL on Blue Sky.
Let's set that up.
But I'm so bad about posting multiple things.
And I tried setting up a thing that would help me cross post at the same time.
And it didn't work at all.
So I was like, oh, okay.
I'll just figure it out eventually.
I'll figure it out eventually.
Yeah, I did try though.
I did try.
And it's hard to leave Twitter.
I'm like, I still have like a copium that'll maybe go back to being good again.
Eventually, maybe.
I like how
their chat is just actual YouTube chat.
The chat that they have on their stream is just YouTube chat.
Twitter is where the idols are.
I know!
Vanilla chat experience.
That's the chat I use.
What do you mean?
Just Google chat, YouTube chat CSS, and you'll find ones that you can semi-customize for free.
You don't have to use just the YouTube box.
Here, hold on.
I'll do it.
I can link you one right now.
YouTube chat CSS.
Here.
This one is a really popular one.
There you go.
You're welcome!
Where is the other one?
Oh, this one is the other one that I've used before.
That's another one that I've used before.
I've seen other people use it before.
Well guys, I'm gonna go to sleep.
Actually, no, I can't go to sleep.
I have to pack.
Oh gosh, I have to pack, I have to do, I have to clean.
I have so much to do!
Thanks for the roulette!
I'm going to commission you cosplaying Kasen in Otter Recover.
So happy for you.
Have fun in Japan and say hi to Ayami Mama for us.
I will!
I will, I will, I will.
Congratulations again on the calamity.
Thank you!
Since we're just chilling here for a second...
Here we go.
Have a good trip and make sure, well, make some good memories, Minky.
See you in the new year.
P.S.
I think Ria P's song with Polka must have gotten auto-flagged or something.
I noticed that too, that it got taken down.
I'm so sad.
But I hope you guys have a wonderful new year.
And thanks for hanging out with me today.
Even though it was a little bit shorter than usual and everything.
Safe travels, Minto.
Hope you have a great time in Japan.
Try not to go too crazy.
Oh, we'll try not to go too crazy.
Yeah, please.
Hot dog.
Have a safe flight.
Fun trip.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Congrats on the collab.
ZUN collab win.
You know...
Wait, I can't say that.
Sorry.
They did say that they will probably show ZUN my cover.
Because they have done so for other covers before in the past.
Which scares me.
Which means ZUN will know of my existence.
That's so crazy.
Wow.
But I'm gonna miss you guys.
I'll miss you guys.
I'll try to post lots.
At least on Twitter.
I'll try to post more on Blue Sky.
I think I'm logged in on there on my phone.
But you guys be good.
Don't cause so much mischief.
Don't... Don't... Don't become too freaky.
I don't know.
I mean, yes, be freaky, but like...
Take care, have fun.
Yeah, I'm only gonna be gone for like a week and a half, so...
It's not so long.
Have a really new year, Minky!
Thank you!
Thanks, Kayvon!
To use... To use your words, you are the best ever.
What are you talking about?
No child support.
Stop it!
Child support is due next month.
No!
See you next year.
See you next year!
We'll survive.
Yeah.
Party at the maid cafe.
No!
You have to keep it tidy!
She's leaving for bilk.
I... I... I didn't ask for this.
I didn't ask for this.
I'm not ready for this responsibility.
Responsibility!
But, yeah.
I don't know what to say.
I'll miss you guys.
Contrary to popular belief, I like streaming.
Thanks, Fireflies!
Here's to... To...
Here's to a great 2025.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
We don't have much left of 2024, so...
But I know that 2025 will be so, so great.
Lots of things already planned.
And we're starting off already with a bang with Toho last words, so...
It's pretty exciting, I think.
I'll see you guys when I get back.
And I will be back.
I'll be back.
Last hot dog of the year.
There it is!
There it is.
Wed 3 for 2025.
Be on the lookout.
Thank you!
Thank you for the hot dogs!
Have a good trip!
See you next year!
Can you do the stream again?
Alright.
One more time!
Monkey!
Bye bye!
Otsumito!
See you next year!
Bye bye!
Have a safe and fun new year!